Hello, how are you greeting Héctor Mejía
with his brief information for today, Thursday
, August 5? The governor, if he alone,
signed a new order that will impact the
return to classes of students in
Clark County and Guangzhou, all
students and staff
must  wear masks inside
buildings and on buses
regardless of whether they are vaccinated or not
those students staff and
volunteers who participate in
activities that require travel outside
of the county will be required to have
weekly screenings this order is
for public private and
charter kindergarten schools  until grade 12 today
there will be a back to school fair at
the world recreation center from 4 to 7
at night about 2
thousand backpacks will be given out in addition to
free dental services and for vision
they will also be offering vaccinations
against cubit and if you have  an
eviction order you can get help
from the organization ligo later
call the number  but on screen this center
offers totally free clinics
where they inform how to prevent an
eviction order
the first will be lifted august 14 from
9 am to noon inside
the ni berger center near owens and
bruce street there is information available
for both tenants  as owners
for more details visit our page
news.com diagonal in Spanish and now we
go to the weather forecast there will be
some breezes for today however we
will remain in very
hot temperatures exceeding 100 degrees these
winds could be 25 to 30 miles
per  hour for the afternoon and they will extend
until tomorrow this would help the
temperatures to drop reaching the
weekend have a nice day electro mejía greets you
this was your brief
spanish broadcast news